so if i'm going to come directly at you
my subconscious
knows that this can't work
because i'm coming directly at you don't
mean
you might be stronger than me so my
subconscious will say to me if i listen
to it
you have to divert one way or the other
and you'll say but anybody would know
that
but will they we do it
so my subconscious now pretend i'm doing
something my subconscious will say
i can't
i can't meet them head-on so i'm going
to fade off
if i fade off oh no i've got to fade off
this way and it becomes an error
if i if i get to doing it mechanically
and i go
i don't know if i'll go
or mote that's the bit when shall i buy
this uh new camera
i already know the answer gentlemen it's
just i'm not listening to it so when i
come here i fade off
so that the person goes
it didn't
happen you know you go ah it didn't
happen
so you can
get their advantage
so what you're doing with the ken
is
you're
i shouldn't say tricking them but you're
you're actually you're not just saying
i'm just going to hold it and hope for
the best
this hand i gave you this hand to do it
with because this hand is easier because
if you need a bit of strength you can
you know oh yeah i'm fine
i'm not using strength you can get away
with it
but this hand is the wrong way look
because it's going that so if i do
nothing if i just go
oh this won't work
then and he pushes
no way you know
but if i'm already programmed like i'm
going to come up here i'm going to dip
it a bit i'm going to push it like that
but i mustn't let him know because if he
sees me he'll counter it so i just come
up and i hold it he thinks of he thinks
that uh oh i didn't do anything but i've
done everything
just certainly and i can play around
with
with things while he's still putting the
same pressure in
so when we so let's do this uh it's best
done on your knees if you're okay on
your knees it's best done on your knees
and it's best done but please daddy
so what um coco dozer what happens is
you do shomenuchi
you take them down
if i leave a gap you remember me saying
a little while ago about if i look at
the fan in the other room and i lose it
so if i'm here and i go
oh okay let's go back i'll have another
go
i've completely lost this connection
unless i'm super good you know
where if i go
intensely watching this person
as we get better i can actually fade off
how much strength i'm putting into it
and
you see how now it's getting
it's getting so i'm not having to do
hardly anything
so i start off uh
physically
if there's if i if there's nothing
between us now and we do nothing the
next one's gonna have to be physical as
well
what i do now is this hand even if it's
your little finger
i put it as close as i can to his head
but when he sees that from his eyes
he thinks i'm gonna have to watch myself
i'm gonna have to watch myself he's
close to me
i've taken his mind with a small object
so if i go like that
but you see you thought because i was
talking to you i'd lost him but i
haven't
all right
because i haven't lost him it's only me
that decides
oh the camera's still working
because it's a job to get him you know
it's hard work now
this is hard work
only because i've done it a long time
i don't drop the connection
and oh scentsy would be
like this more
dynamic so therefore that's when you
start seeing the power
and um
you know you start seeing it more like
this
that and you don't have to i won't i've
got bad shoulders so i won't do it
physically but let's just pretend you
know he's coming here and i go so i give
a good old throw
the lighter you can get
the better
just
he comes here i step
and move to that way
i don't just step
get hold of him and throw
watch how i lead him with this part of
my body
so i'm actually going
with him aren't i
so i choose
the the i choose the exit point and then
i
sorry
but yeah that's because i i intent
intended it you know
i forgot where oh you're going to be
doing cookie doughs aren't you okay
thank you